I'm Evander Holyfield my favorite move
is rocky been getting opportunity to go
to many movies
my mother were always gonna put things
in proper priority you know you're gonna
eat before you do anything if you're not
gonna die if you don't go to movies and
you move it when gonna be the first
thing you go to ah the first time I saw
Rocky I was you know I was about 14 to
15 years old and rocker was the guy that
that worked real hard but came from not
too good background but he was tough and
you know even though Rocky was white it
kind of represented me I lived in a
black neighborhood and the people people
who was on the bus and said you ain't no
rocket you blockin they called me up and
and so they looked at the color but I
didn't look at the color I looked at the
motivation what it took I was doing
everything that rocket did cuz if it got
rocket there it could probably get me
there and I was the type of person
everything I did I did the music I love
music I forget about how tired I am and
just run through the music
oh man the music was great put on rewind
just you know over and over and over and
over and you know I ran up to the Stepp
man I helped my hands up real high and
you know punching in the air and he took
the raw X and I started doing wrong it
made me think about all these all these
great things happen because I was able
to see the movie of Rocky
he'll fight anybody and here's the guy
that the winds are harder people cause
he just wouldn't quit Mike Tyson had
that great things that you don't
everybody got a plan to they get hit and
he were absolutely right when he hit
them guys they change their mind and so
the whole big thing about Rocky this
site look having heart I knew exactly
weighted going through it
was in a movie I realized that you know
we're till get to get up from the ground
and have the will to win it's got the
big one your greatest feeling in the
world that you you made it up regardless
to whether you want to fight or not she
gave all that he had he never pretend to
be nobody else
he was just Rocky I gave my heart I gave
my arms so the point of the matter when
you give you all that's it and you just
stand up and be proud that you was able
to give you all we realize that you know
the world wouldn't be what it is
it's people quit we here today car we
didn't quit rocket represent everybody
in America because the fact is is that
everybody came to a mirror of what
America dream and part of America dream
is not quit I'm Eve an order via I love
movies take one
you
you